i start to perform stand-up comedy okay
and one guy yelled from the back what is
the best heckle i've ever heard in my
life
really he yelled excuse me sir i think i
speak for everyone here when i say that
we would enjoy
silence more than the sound of your
voice
what yes uh what's the best
heckle that's been thrown your way or
most
memorable there's too many man
um all right
we'll go around we'll go around the uh
all right when i was black room best one
i ever got i was bombing
at this place used to be called mixed
nuts it's now called the comedy union
and i was up there
and dude when i tell you five minutes of
straight silence dry mouth
nothing and it was the summertime when
sound carries right
and i'm just going and going and it's
nothing and nothing and then just in the
middle of one of my jokes i'm meandering
in this long setup for something else
that's going to bomb
this big black lady in the back just out
loud to nobody just sort of looked
around and said like
i laughed yet and the whole place
exploded laughing and
i didn't know how to deal with it i
didn't know i had to address it i kept
trying to do my material
and then they were just laughing at me
trying to do man it was
[ __ ] humiliating um
and that's i don't know there's one uh
i'll tell you the weirdest one i got um
i've told this one before one of the
weirdest ones i got i was at danger
fields
doing the midnight show and it was just
one of those nights
everybody was bombing the place was
packed and nobody was laughing
i remember the guy in front of me like
he was just
bombing so bad and he was in on some
show where he played a bartender
and he had gotten beaten up he's like oh
yeah you guys see that movie he's trying
to hit you guys see this movie blah blah
blah blah he goes i yeah i played the
bartender
the you know the the star of the movie
beat this you know beat the [ __ ] out of
me you guys see that and then some kid
in the back just goes
he should have killed you
so i was like oh and that guy walked
past me never even looked at me he just
when he got off stage he just had this
flop sweat and just walked by me just
going wow
wow and then i went on stage immediately
bombing
and there was this group of kids in the
corner these white dudes and they were
just like just ready for a fight they
were just super [ __ ] hot
that whole my dad used to beat the [ __ ]
out of me vibe
yeah and everything i had learned up to
that point was like bill
don't get into it with them i heard him
talking and i was like don't say
anything
don't say anything and then finally i
just it's this [ __ ] thing when you're
on stage as a comic
you think like this and this is like
some sort of like a [ __ ] gun in
bullets but it isn't it's just
plastic [ __ ] and i just like i finally
said i go hey you know what's going on
over there what are you guys talking
about
and blah blah i can't remember what i'm
saying this guy just finally was just
yelled out
you know i had the he goes anything just
yells out he goes anything
red in on stage is a [ __ ]
right and it was the most childish
heckle i ever got this is back when like
people didn't freak out about that word
you guys like oh my god what does that
say about gay people
this was when straight people used it it
just meant you were an [ __ ]
and um so he said that i just remembered
like i didn't know what to do it was
just like it was so [ __ ]
childish but i also knew he was gonna
like beat the [ __ ] out of me so i just
went like
right back into my state my act like
this almost like a cooties joke you know
this right here the reaction to that is
why you can never leave the comedy clubs
by the way
like because that used to be a funny
story but now because of like
that's not gay people said what that
word makes us feel like
now everybody even if you say it and you
say that somebody else said it to you
it becomes this weird thing of like well
does he advocate what he said but
probably just becomes all of that and
becomes like
context and all of that [ __ ] so well
that's what he said
what do you got tom uh i was just i went
to a patricia's show friday night
and he killed phil and he destroyed this
old
table of old people it was hilarious
yeah danny came in today he saw patrice
governors and danny said that
it was like a war i mean most of the
people
sat and did what they should do enjoy
the comedian if you're not enjoying them
let other people enjoy them it's that
that's the
that's the shut up that's all a comedian
asked for
sit down just let everybody else if the
whole room's not enjoying it
then maybe you should be able to
do your thing it was just you know it
was it wasn't even that amazing it was
just
some entitled long island broad and her
beat down husband what happened i heard
there were cops involved
yes then one of the karate chops super
rich and she was karate chopping at the
cops
saying i'm better than you hi yeah the
cops showed up
they came they showed up because the guy
stood up the guy jimmy that owns the
place
he finally had to move him away because
i was on this guy's wife
because when you know when a woman's
heckling i don't say anything to the
woman i talk to the guy that goes
does this belong to you and i just
started what did she say to start the
whole thing
she's just um anything i said is like
yeah whatever
and i look at all loud yeah all drunk
and loud and i look at this guy
and i go let me show you something about
about women and i and i say look she's
not gonna be able to talk unless i
continue to talk myself she has nothing
to say
so i sat there and she had nothing to
say she went you're just
stupid and you're gonna bother my friend
so i just looked at and she finally shut
up
so when i talked then she talked again
and then it was on so i would have to
constantly berate him
and berate her through him and like kept
calling her it
does does it belong to you and and
calling her man swears you know what i
mean
and oh guys i don't like hearing that
yeah i just called him and he said i
didn't come here
to watch you insult my wife i said so
tell her to shut up
so i don't have to insult it no more is
everyone applauding as you're saying
it was a must-have party is that what
that dummy did he sided with her even
though she was
even though she was wrong yeah so he
stood up and then he started calling me
names and everything
and then he he called me a [ __ ] and
then said did he go for the you know
go for the what the racial angle no he
was scared to do that i think he did
that
outside i heard he was calling me all
kind of uh n words but not using anymore
the actual
sure sure the authentic one so but he
goes
he goes come outside and i go i already
know you're
you can't even control your wife you're
not gonna be able to control me
and then what's the matter with your
fists right now they get better outside
[Laughter]
and the crowd starts singing
but then she had a friend of course you
know ladies always stick up for
and and they just it was three of them
they just got my face and she goes out
right for the
something something something and i
would destroy this place and the cops
came to try to throw her
out and she karate kicked at him
she old lady karate kicked haya karate
kicked out it was hayakurani yeah
karate kick and said i will not you
would not i'm better than you
it was it was just in the crowd but
unbelievably the crowd they
gave a standing ovation during that
whole thing it was it was so
crazy but they had to leave they were
poisoned but it was just this
this drunk came in with a limo didn't
know who i was
kind of this shows about me and the guy
goes he says
get him off the stage and i said
it was a headliner i go it makes more
sense for you to leave
than for me to leave because it's it's
all over when i'm gone
[Laughter]
when you go you still go on stop being
selfish your whole life
get out he wants you to get off the
stage and wreck
everyone's good times oh man go amazing
wait tell us a story about the the dad
and the son the irishman
dad and the son in calgary oh my god i
mean
what i'm on stage
and i talk about you know the bit i do
about going to a brothel in thailand oh
yeah yeah
how a woman's eating my butthole and all
that
and i do the bit and it crushes
and from the back of the room i see this
little leprechaun stand up
he's wearing green oh he's an
eight-year-old irishman i can't do
anything was he really wearing green
yeah he was he was wearing a top hat i
don't know about that but
it could be one of those things like you
know you yourself
correct me yeah yeah
yeah yeah conor mcgregor
yeah and he goes you think that's funny
that's not bad that's what he says and i
go
yeah they laughed that's not funny
right i challenged you and i go well
they [ __ ] laugh
right people are laughing at this point
still yeah yeah
and i go um so then i don't know if you
guys see my act but
i do a lap dance thing at the end oh and
i
picked his nephew
who was like 22 year old kid yeah right
and i go i want to show you funny did he
volunteer
or you just said he did volunteer but
there was a lot of people that
volunteered yeah
and i just honed right in on the left
for confidence and i go leprechaun look
right and i went so sexual
and i could see him get up and walk out
of the room